what's the title that's going to be
anyway
i'm not sure we should talk about that
i mean a female sex addict is actually
called a nymphomaniac yeah i've been
called enough to info before
i don't know if i am or not but i
haven't call them
so you actually flew in last night but
your first person meeting was it was a
guy that you arranged to meet yeah and
you got somewhere to stay tonight
so you spent the night with him yeah
where'd you meet him
phet i just made a post i came one la
who i had all kinds of messages this
online
hook-up hookup thing
yeah and how often do you do that
flying out i've only flown out once or
twice but until now
like and you're in your typical
probably new dicks i don't know
like for a week that i don't have aubry
i might have sex
10 times
or more
and
usually new people are i don't know a
couple at least so it's like twice a day
yeah
or like a few guys at once or something
oh is that right
this started how soon for you how old
were you when
um i started
so when i actually consentingly
started doing this
teenager of some age
sex was really vanilla for a long time
and then
i just i always like getting snacks and
[ __ ] and
so here we are
how old are you now
i'm 34 84.
you enjoy sex love sex you love it love
sex yes usually
yeah i do and
have you had committed relationships
before i was in a relationship for nine
years with my daughter's father
um
and then a few years of my ex and
and that that was you were also
doing things on the side
no
no i was committed it was just us
um towards the end i was like whatever
and i'd stick with that people or
whatever but not not while we were
together what to
so you you became single you were free
to do whatever you liked and i just took
advantage of it went had fun
and you're working
i'm sorry you're working you have a job
yeah yeah
i've been influenced 15 years old
and are drugs a part of your life um i
have a past history of drug addiction
pain pills mainly
so but no longer no no longer alcohol i
drink
how much is it a lot or just not as much
as i used to drink i used to drink at
least 30 beers a day plus whiskey
um
i don't drink anywhere near that now but
it's still enough that it's too much
on my floss does it does it help to open
up
you know
make things move
more quickly
because i assume you're meeting people
and then it turns sexual very quickly
having sex with them like does the
alcohol help with that i don't drink for
that reason um but i'm sure it
definitely
alleviates some tension and what not
meeting somebody new and doing that
so
that's not why i drink
how do your
hookups usually go
um
typically i'll just go to their house or
something or
and it's understood what you're both
there for yeah
yeah it's very clear like we talk about
sex we send pictures
i get explicit things about what they're
going to do to me
um and
it just happens we do it
so there's always that awkward tension
like when you first get there like
um
so now what
so that's really annoying when it's
really bad like we know we both know why
i'm here why are we just standing here
like kind of thing but
yeah
you must have some crazy stories
yes
um
anything in particular you want
or just whatever you're in the mood to
share
um i think i shared with you about the
uh
guy that wanted me to be his sex slave
live in his basement
locked up
and
then
me pregnant i will sign over all rights
to my child
and better remain a slave in the
baseball him and his wife raise it raise
my child um never met him never had a
conversation with him before this
nothing he wanted you to consent to
being a sex slave and yeah just getting
pregnant by him and giving him my kid
um in the basement of their house yeah
yeah like literally
um then there was a guy that wants me to
for 2.5 million dollars
um drill holes through my boobs
um brand my brand them severe breast
torture but
very
on this side of the spectrum rather than
like
bruises or something two and a half
million
yeah it changed my daughter's life um
yeah i don't know i said no he offered
more money he said what would it take
so
strange world out there
some interesting people that's for sure
but typically you're just looking for a
a
more
conventional sexual experience
i wouldn't say conventional um
my favorite is like if i go somewhere
they just grab me tie me up and do
whatever they want i think that's the
best most fun for me to do
but it's a little bit of a dumb sub yeah
yeah
i'm set in bed but outside of bed i'm
very independent
so
what are the what are the best ways of
meeting these kind of partners
i tell you fetlife is
where i've met majority of them
i've met people at stores or whatever
and hooked up
um
what is the
what are the cues that you get from
somebody in a store
how do you make that happen
oh god that's a good question
um
i don't know i just get certain looks
i've actually been to a grocery store a
lot i've never seen anything i've never
if you give a girl a look the right way
never know what could happen i don't
know
but i don't know there's certain looks
that i get or something and get talking
by chance about something and it just
goes from there
have you ever
gotten attached to anyone you're hooking
up with
somewhat i don't allow myself to get
really attached um there's a couple
people that really
there's a guy right now that i'm talking
to
we're friends um we met on phet
he's very new to the scene
and lifestyle
and
he's wonderful
he's just going to have a long marriage
so this is fun for him i don't know i
care i've really i care about him a lot
um but i can't get too close because it
sucks
so
you know that kind of thing happens i
guess i am a woman
i do have feelings like
so but usually no no feelings
after care just go away from me like
we're done bye
after care being what
um i don't know after
after you're done like cuddles or do you
want you to drink or touching and
there's kindness after the yeah kindness
out of the eye yeah pretty much
emotional physical whatever it may be
and you're not into it you would just
rather move on and
typically yeah depending on who it's
with if i'm there and i'm just here to
[ __ ] that's it we're [ __ ] and i'm
gonna i've actually slept guys on the
ass and said good game as i walked by
walking out the door and they're like
what
because like would you want me to fall
in love with you or something like
we both know why i'm here do you get
guys getting attached to you
um
clingy stalkerish types
seem to be what it is the most
like bad like i don't want people to
know where i live
um a lot of people know where i live
like in town or whatever
but
if i don't know you at all you're not
getting my address chances are typically
there's been exceptions but
my daughter lives there i live there our
stuff is there
i'm not gonna have just anybody coming
over and
yeah crazy people in the world
are there a lot of people that are
uh
interacting like this
what do you mean just they're just so
[Music]
just trading partners every day
um i think in the
world itself there is like in the sec
world of sex
there's a lot of people on the side that
you wouldn't expect to be on that site
professionals
um
things like that
but i think there is a lot of people
that have a high turnover um what i've
heard what i've been told is that women
are not usually like me i don't know
i think typically men are
typically it's the men that are like
[ __ ] christmas persons right so
yeah
but i don't know i'm sure i'm not the
only one
of my friends i'm the only one that i
know of so
yeah no i've i've known and heard of
other women that are
i'm sure there's others like this yeah
not personally
what uh
where do you think this comes from
i would guarantee childhood abuse
is where it stems from
without a doubt
tell me about your childhood
um
so
starting as a baby
um
the first guy was very touchy and i
didn't realize it was wrong until i got
older
because i was used to it i grew up with
it but that started at what age
i moved to that place babysitter at six
months old
he was a babysitter babysitter's husband
um
so
i mean i don't know when actually
started because like i said it was just
it was the norm if you sat on grandpa's
lap he tickled you and touched you and
did this and that
um
and then when i turned nine is when
another guy started giving me tequila
started watching porn with me
um
touching
i'm pinning to the bed
all that beating me daily um with the
belt without fancy panties pulled down
um that's something i still can't do is
have men spanking with a belt
you can choke me with a belt whatever
the [ __ ] else you want to do but you
cannot spin with a belt
um
so yeah
i think all stems from that
mainly the second guy thank you
mess my makeup up
and typically sexual abuse as a child
will either make somebody asexual or
sexual yeah or i'm very hypersexual do
the opposite yeah yeah i go there's
first where i'm like uh i don't feel
like having sex today you know like but
then i go through spurts where i'm like
oh my god i'm gonna have sex ten times a
day like it just depends on my mood i
guess i don't know have you seen
therapists anything like that um yeah
actually i have seen a lot there has it
helped at all not i haven't seen four of
this i've seen them for like ptsd and
things like that
i take antidepressants every day what
you do
and anxiety medicine
so
what are the most partners you've had in
the day
um seventh most in one day so i could
think of like yeah
seven different partners yeah six six
was pretty much at once and then
oh i see yeah and then one before that
does it make you happy
it helps me forget about life for a
little bit
it's just a
it's like a drug
yeah kinda it's an addiction
for sure
that's what it is
helps me cope
better than banging dope or something so
in my head i feel that way
and your family you've talked about this
with your parents really um they don't
like it
um they don't like that i'm here no but
do they understand why it came about
they it was under their watch
that's a whole other episode
um
they
know
it's not really acknowledged
well
the way i think it should be
it definitely should be yeah it goes on
a lot yeah and i'm very vocal about it
um the second guy was actually my
stepdad
um he's still in my mom's life
what was it right
so
there's a lot of them it's amazing how
many oh [ __ ] i deal with what's that
it's amazing how many of them are
protected
it's ridiculous
so it's whatever
let's go learn how to deal with it aubry
can't go see her grandma whenever she
wants and
i don't go over there
you have good memories of your
your childhood
yeah um before my subject came in the
picture yeah
mom likes to travel go camping a lot i
might grow up on a boat with dad at the
lake all the time
um or in the woods
so i'm very outdoorsy and i get that
honest
from both between those two
um they are divorced they were divorced
when i was about i think two years old
um
and so that everybody's like oh it's
because you have a broken family and
like that doesn't bother me that's what
i know
i wasn't happily living happily with
them together for 12 years then they
divorced it was my whole life it's like
that basically
but um you had divorced parents and
but yeah boating with dad camping with
mom
traveling that kind of thing
so it was nice but the abuse that you
went through as a kid does that
change things
change like just your relationships well
just your mental state as a kid
i didn't realize yeah so
the first guy
like i didn't realize it was wrong
so it was just what it was
um the second guy was very very very
abusive and
um
he
my grades went from like a straight a
student to straight ups like in one year
done
over with
um boys
everything just
everything that i was doing was
sidetracked all the ones
so
is that when alcohol came into your life
too well he started giving me alcohol
when i was nine oh really yeah tequila
so
um
yeah that's when my dad's on college as
well
so i think that's i get it from that
and then
that
if i stepped out of my dad like they're
[ __ ]
so i think that's
that's where it came from
wow
is it it must affect you emotionally
like you're depressed or
either angry stuff like that yeah i had
um
i can't say too much on it but my
depression last year got really bad um
it's better now than i was but still i'm
struggling yeah no i would think
somebody seeing
a person that's tight you know videos
titled menthol maniac would be like
would be oh my god this girl's having
the time of her life but i think there's
a lot of pain behind it there is
a lot
it's just a coping mechanism yeah
i mean i could travel like and come here
and
want to the beach after this you know
and stuff i don't get to do at home
but it has it's not easy
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
what do you mean i mean just in life in
general not not relating to
this aspect of your life but just like
finances yeah like a lot of us
yeah especially with what i'm doing for
work right now i doesn't pay the best
and
my bills are huge and
my house is old so it's hard to heat and
it's just
it's a lot
do you feel in any way this derailed
your life and you wanted that maybe you
had dreams of doing something else and
um i actually want to be a veterinarian
i had a full scholarship to university
of michigan for swimming
and
was on track to at least at least
compete in the olympic trials
for swimming
and my senior year i had a car accident
broke my pelvis in eight places
and i lost my scholarship because you
can't swim if you can't even walk
so um i got take my med flight down to
grant might fly by land
down to great hospital our area's
largest trauma center
and um
woke up and it was gone everything i
wanted was gone
are your
sexual escapades somehow
they get in the way of your life and
your
job as a parent or anything like that no
when i have my daughter it's my daughter
i'm mom you compartmentalize yeah
i obviously i'm not gonna have a bunch
of men over around her
i don't even know like i'm not doing
that so when you
you you share time with your daughter
yeah we do week on week off um so when i
have her it's strictly like
well i have friends who come over and
stuff don't get me wrong like just hang
out or whatever eat dinner whatever that
may be
um but it's strictly mom like
i can't be [ __ ] everybody that i see
because i just want dick you know like i
can't i can't do that
i don't want to put her in danger
obviously so
are you lonely am i lonely
i have nights where i wish i was laying
next to somebody or something but
but even even
even those kind of relationships that
you're that you're having
often
are those satisfying in terms of
companionship are they just kind of not
because there's a companionship
um
if i need something i mean i'm like i'll
call somebody you know usually there's
some people to help me with whatever
that's nice like a boyfriend would help
you with something
but
um other than that
emotional needs aren't really met
typically at all
except for like one person what kind of
emotions does it bring up after after
having some of these
like after sex yeah i mean is there
shame or is there
is it just joy is it just fun
exercise
explain it it's not it's not shame i
don't have a sense of shame i probably
should have more of a sense of shame
um
but
for me i don't know it's just
i can breathe like all my weights lift
off my shoulders for a minute and it's
like
you know just
then reality happens again i gotta go
back to life
so
you have any regrets in your life any
regrets in my life
um
yeah
nothing really
like my biggest regret right now is not
going to the east coast when i was in
santa cruz to see the sunrise like
i've done stuff i regret but i mean
nothing really
very poignant that sticks out to me or
anything like oh my god i should have
done that i regret driving on the ice so
fast and totally my car and there's no
scholarship yeah but nothing
else really
i regret not
i regret i guess i do regret
um being beaten and just saying that i
made up this stuff with my stepdad
um by him not my mom she's she was
wonderful
um
but i do regret not i regret saying i
made it up
that's what i regret
jessica what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
to appreciate things
if you have a good life don't [ __ ] it up
just appreciate if you have somebody's
good do you appreciate them whether it
be family boyfriend whatever
i don't know how to explain it
that's something that's really big with
me
all right jessica thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you takes a lot
of courage right it's hard
thank you very much
you